people always want to sell something
when it comes to weight loss and health
right so they reinvent the wheel for
that reason and I'm sure you've seen a
variety of fad diets whether it's oh you
know right now we're going vegan wait no
we're going paleo wait no it's thirty
thirty forty equal portions of
everything wait a second we can do
everything but eat beans it just it
always it goes on and on and on and the
reality is that weight loss weight
maintenance is simple science it's eat
less move more food that you consume has
calories and it calories or units of
energy energy that does not get burned
gets stored as fat fat is stored energy
and then obviously use common sense with
your food choices we all know not to eat
things in our food that is not food fake
fat fake flavor fake sugar and so on so
in reality if it is this simple
being healthy why do so many struggle
with it and that's because people
utilize food for a variety of emotional
reasons whether it's a coping mechanism
or whether it's affording them a deeper
connection with another individual in
their lives and that's what we have to
get to the bottom of and I remember
somebody once said to me people are fat
because they want to be fat and I
remember going what an a-hole you are
and the more I thought about it the more
I realized it was true the more I began
to work with people who were overweight
the more I began to see what it meant to
them and it could have been a connection
with the parents it could have been a
connection to grieving the loss of
somebody and feeling like if you stop
eating like this you've moved on with
your life and you're no longer connected
to them it could be a sense of control
it could be a defense mechanism against
being vulnerable and getting hurt in
relationships but that is one of the
reasons that losing weight or getting
healthy is so difficult because it
requires us to give up something that
has been providing comfort and a defense
against hurt for a very
long time it's not because people are
weak or stupid or lazy or genetically
fat it's funny I ask people a lot of
times right and if I was to ask you
right now why is it that you want to be
healthy and I would always ask
contestants on The Biggest Loser first
day right and they would show up and
they would get on the scale cuz they
would get on the scale before they ever
had their first workout and they would
be like I'm changing my life I'm never
gonna see this number again I'm changing
the world
I'm changing my neighborhood my school
my family my partner my so on and so
forth right five minutes into the first
workout they're rolling on the floor
they're crawling for the door they're
crying they're throwing up and in that
moment I was like okay so now why did
you come here why did you want to come
to this place this place is not easy
being healthy is hard work what is it
and they would say well I want I just
want to be healthy and I would go great
what does that mean to you and then I
would get like the Scooby Doo it was
work and people don't think about it
they really don't know if I was to ask
you right now what does health look like
in your life what's your answer is it I
want to wear a two-piece instead of a
one-piece that's spring break because
I'm 22 or is it I want to see my
grandchildren graduate from college
because I'm 62 or is it you know what I
want to have sex with the lights on
which by the way I think is tremendously
overrated but nevertheless it's not dark
all the time whatever your motivation is
that's what's critical and it could be
that you're a new mom it could be that
you want to wear skinny jeans it could
be that you want to run a marathon you
need to think about what ways health
will improve the quality of your life
because I'm gonna tell you right now
that getting healthy usually is dis
pleasurable most of us would rather be
watching our favorite TV show than
sweating it out at the gym most of us
not all but most most of us would prefer
pizza to grilled salmon and so it
order for these behaviors in the moment
that are less than pleasurable to become
manageable you've got to have
perspective and a long-term goal that's
worth it and we call that finding your
why there's a great quote if you have a
why to live for you can tolerate the how
and the how is the work and the
sacrifice associated with the goal and
so this is where you need to ask
yourself some really powerful questions
of what is it that I want for myself in
detail what do I want for my future how
do I see this improving the quality of
my life and you might find in the
beginning you draw a complete blank and
the reason for this is because so many
of us live in the way that we think we
should that we've forgotten what it is
we really want so I have an exercise for
you
I want you for the next two weeks to set
your alarm on the hour every hour waking
hours only I'm not a complete monster
and when it goes off I want you to ask
yourself what you're doing right now in
the moment and then subsequently how
does it make you feel and by teaching
yourself to become present you're better
able to start identifying the things
that you do want that you are passionate
about and that will help you start to
cultivate your why